hello everybody and welcome to let's
play from dust part 4 as you will know
we just left off a tidal wave just
happened and I'm gonna try to get my
guys to this thing so that I can move on
vegetations had a hundred percent the
animals have stopped by is weird freaky
freaky things I'm just messing around
till they get their drop off there
alright and looted doo dee doo dee doo
alright that's enough of that
Oh move faster oh you so slow
why am i moving backwards what's
happening white what what what all right
that was cool
kinda whatever let's see oh I see
I forgot the controls I'm so stupid I
forgot that the mouse follows this
little worm guy alright almost there
Go Go old man not you you're not an old
man but you are a woman sorry
sorry yep already
seems pretty cool to me bang on your
drums it's just a door why do you need
to bang drums to get in maybe there's
like some sort of magical barrier that
they got a breakdown before they go in
oh yeah that looks like a barrier I'm
waiting come on now
ah there we go aha that's again a
ladyada Oh lose our money maybe I'd ow
you don't bangle exercise Janine Yahoo
same one that seems likely to I'm
catching on this is the same cutscene in
everyone
oh how dare they how dare they
okay new place I'm hoping that there's
gonna be more types of like ah yes
spells powers in taxes as Amani doc
Menino Cali a happy to Madera Tasha raga
body uh-huh
alright built my first village I want
some sort of like something to really
change the earth cuz I know everything
is terraformable
not just sand so whoa what the oh wow
that's something
wow that is something holy crapoly my
goodness gracious
that's very cool very very cool
oh yeah all right
endless tsunamis use the lava oh hell
yeah oh yeah I like that
can I get to the love I don't need them
to get the lovin hey let me fill up this
thing try to get that clear cuz that
looks at the fork
I guess Oh oh yeah
oh look at that I like it oh wow it's
cool
I should not dump this on my village
that is something that I I probably
shouldn't do no matter how tempting it
is alright
build it up nice and good I guess I got
to let it cool a bit before I keep
adding so that it'll build them up and
not just melt back down all that is cool
this game is so neat Oh dick you lessly
neat give me yo lava gimme gimme gimme
all right no more oh yeah little more
little more little more okay okay what
is the the power though I know this
isn't the power
cuz that other power blocking the wave
or the water at least in the other one
that wasn't me doing it that was my
people and as great as they are I wanted
to do something oh oh I didn't sound
good a my there's a little no bet more
all right go people it's totally safe
was that jellify water did that say
jellify water turn water into gel I
suppose
all right take your word for it
jellify water okay just make double
extra sure that this isn't gonna look
kill everybody I would feel bad I feel
bad when I do it I'd feel even worse if
someone else did it nature all right
you do your thing to the stone there the
totem rather oh no oh oh oh oh oh man
one thing I'm amazed by is the the shear
you know area at which things are
simulated like it's just amazing
okay jellify water absorb up the congeal
water to open ah okay
oh okay this should be useful and see
how this works
jellify what that do oh whoa
wiggity wiggity whack oh I better hurry
I suppose well there's no stopping this
so good thing I did that I don't know I
don't know I got to get my guys like
right at the edge and then let him you
know so I'm pretty sure they'll stop on
their own I don't think that that's
stupid but maybe maybe I'll let him try
I'll let him try
all right
I wonder if this simulation is so good
that the waves eventually would just
like erode away everything I built up
here maybe it's getting pretty close
there whoa hello none of that sir
none of that yeah I know you I know you
need my help I'll be there I'm busy
leave me alone ha so needy
alright okay okay alright
jellify water is it up again oh I see is
recharging up there come on now there's
the other one do before nothing nothing
what oh we useless totem useless you are
alright uh hold on oh no oh no I don't
die what the hell why did you why why oh
no seriously don't die oh hello
it's it's not that serious
you know wait just a little bit longer
the bars gonna refill any minute now
alright okay now that your patient
goodness okay I hear you
are you ready you ready okay
let's make sure your you're gonna go
right you're gonna go okay here we go
jellify water but oh it's not the douche
there we go
ah ah I'm hurrying quick as I can man
that jellified all the water
azam powerful so I guess I did dump it
right here go go oh my goodness go are
you really that stupid
I guess you are gosh oh come on it's
right there it's right in front of your
face oh I'm pulling a serious Moses here
and you're just gonna stand in there
well fine fu I'll get other disciples to
go ah I've got three people here that's
two less than I need and one of you is
completely useless
two of you rather there's who hello oh I
forgive you
oh I can't I can't stay mad at you aw
you look so bad
hello baby all right enough of that come
on oh my goodness golly gosh and there
goes my power fantastic thank you so
much oh I really appreciate it man
guess suck oh I should just dump lava
right on your heads but I won't do that
I mean I help you I'm gonna stop being
so helpless
all right I don't think it matters
really how quick nod does it does it
matters how quick I put it up oh you
gotta wait you gotta wait like everybody
else because you were oh well that
doesn't look good
uh-uh pick it up pick it up
oh no I won't let you die oh you're not
endangered
this is danger
all right a little more Omar there we go
all right oops whoops start pausing
again
Oh hold on oh there we go okay it's time
you get rid of this all right you better
be ready go go oh my goodness go there
we go there we go finally Oh take ten
billion hours why don't you oh don't
stop you got nothing to be afraid of
that's right go you better hurry
Oh nonchalantly man you walk fast though
then you're walking - that girl was
running you were still at the same pace
so good on you I guess all right do it
sing your songs bang your drums play
your didgeridoos yeah there we go oh no
that was a wall water or something
with the volcano was it volcano wow that
is still cool I don't know how they do
that it's like fluid physics on top of
the the earth but water isn't the same
or is it
they're just water am I just making a
big deal out of nothing probably see
this
okay oh hello
I can go the next level now but I won't
cuz there's more stuff to do
uh-huh
I wonder how big I can build a dam all
that was cool sploosh huh cool alright
anyway oh I have to cut it here thank
you guys so much for watching and I will
see you in part 5 of let's play from
dust bye bye